ahead of quantum breaks release in early
April digital foundry has analyzed a
pre-release version of the game and
discovered that it may run at 720p I'm
Lucy and welcome to this time bending
gamespot news update a white paper from
developer remedy published in 2015
suggested the game or at least some
elements of it would run at 1080p but
digital foundry has said that it is yet
to see evidence of Full HD 1080p
gameplay it reported in every scene
tested so far a native resolution of
720p is the consistent result found in
each pixel count test so while there's
every possibility of individual render
targets operating at higher resolutions
basic geometry that we're able to
measure hands in a 720p result as things
stand digital foundry goes on to say the
quantum break even at its reported 720p
resolution still remains visually
impressive and stunning in many areas
this is apparently made possible through
remedies use of post effects such as
film grain and motion blur along with
anti-aliasing added to this image
quality appear sharper and noticeably
cleaner in more static scenes where a
pixel count suggests something closer to
a 900 p % ation a temporal
reconstruction anti-aliasing solution is
a strong contender a technique where
information from previously rendered
frames is blended with the current one
remedy has not yet responded to digital
foundries report it's possible that the
final resolution will be higher or that
even its sub 1080p the game will still
look great after all resolution isn't
everything Digital phantom reports that
quantum break runs at a steady 30 frames
per second even during effects heavy
combat sections it's also worth noting
that this is the report from the Xbox
one edition of quantum break the pc
version may end up looking and
performing better on more powerful rigs
be sure to check out the full digital
foundry report as it has loads more
details and analysis on quantum breaks
resolution and performance link is on
the screen now is 720p a deal-breaker
for you or do you just want the game to
look and run as best it can be sure to
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games for more on quantum break
keep a gamespot
you